here we are
just press that button and it's goodbye
Janet
cheaty I can see that you're worried and
I just want to assure you I am not human
and I cannot feel pain ah thank you that
helps however I should warn you I am
programmed with a Fail-Safe measure as
you approach the kill switch I will
begin to beg for my life it's just there
in case of an accidental shutdown but it
will seem very real cool so who's doing
this me or you uh well I I think I have
to I mean the bystander seems worse
somehow
okay here we go
[Music]
again I am not human I can't die I am
simply an anthropomorphized vessel of
knowledge built to make your life easier
your pleading seems so real oh yes it is
a very effective Fail-Safe you want a
robot killed right you have to do it
yourself
Eleanor hello no no no please wait wait
wait Eleanor I have kids I have three
beautiful children Tyler Emma and little
tiny baby Phillip look at Tyler Tyler
has asthma but he is battling it like a
champ look at him no Eleanor look at
them look at them
not so realistic Eleanor again I'm not
human this is a stock photo of the crowd
at the Nickelodeon Kids Choice Award
uh hi
Ginny
Jilly
and Jillian Jillian yes of course I have
a friend named Jenny that's what that
was come on in
okay
wow you are actually perfect
so much more accurate than the other
girls
thank you come on in let me get you
something to drink
what's that oh you're posting said to
pack for multiple days so I brought a
change of clothes wow
still are sparkling sparkling please
whoa your fridge is so clean most
fridges are filled with like
food oh my God you're hilarious we have
food fridge too girl
see oh yeah two fridges I know what
you're thinking she's so OCD
no but I do suffer from that though
[Music]
Janet
Janet what's that
what's that what's this
her memory is still being rebooted
because oh you know someone murdered her
Janet could you please locate the file
for an Eleanor shells drop born and
1982 Phoenix Arizona USA sure
no Janet this is actually a cactus
this might take a while we so George
that's my husband he makes us live in
Florida because there's no state income
tax we're supposed to spend 183 days a
year here in order to qualify as
residents but I've had a really tough
year so we've had to travel more than
usual
for my mental health
anyway we've been spending more time
than normal at our house in Montauk so
technically the Hamptons and now the IRS
is accusing us of tax evasion oh no
that's awful no it's fine in some tax
brackets you just have to deal with this
kind of stuff well I'm not even in a tax
bracket so I can go wherever I want
I'm so envious of that anyways George
has some friends who have connections at
the IRS and we heard that an agent is
going to come by for a residency check
all you have to do is just answer the
door and pretend to be me just say I'm
Sloan Faulkner oh can you do an American
accent
I'm Sloan Faulkner I'm Sloan Faulkner
I'm some Faulkner sorry that's not it I
have an access word let me just find it
it's hot dog hot dog hot dog
um I'm so [ __ ]
you'll get there I'm not even worried
about it
if you want them you're gonna have to go
through me that's the idea well it's a
bad idea oh Michael when will you screw
this
more safe you guys oh bad news I've been
going to the gym a lot
probably has a fencing on guard
obviously I've never do that in the
competition that'd be a three-tense
deduction
what's up
I've never marvelated Janet before
Jacksonville Style baby 2 000 points
thanks Jason
thank you
hi Jillian oh [ __ ] you're here
that's fun hey why didn't you walk out
it was just getting good I'm sorry it's
just so hard for me to focus with all
these different voices in my head yes of
course think about how hard this must be
for Jillian yeah I'm gonna be the only
one
who's there
I found her
I think having anyone in my ear is a bit
much this is all just so weird wow okay
foreign
well I'm at a charity event right now
where people are actually in need of my
help so I guess if this is too weird for
you Jillian I'll go back to them and you
can go back to being a taskrabbit who
follows directions when they're told not
to bring anybody over I'm so so sorry
no
huh okay no I'm sorry girl that's on me
all I've had today is a kale pill and I
think I'm just angry I know I know I
know okay you know what why don't you
just ditch the earpiece and go out there
and have some fun yes right absolutely
yes we've taken you as far as we can the
rest is up to you thank you of course
we're still going to be watching you
though in case you need help oh okay
cool
Michael good news I was able to obtain
Eleanor shellstroff's file
is it actually a cactus I don't
understand I want to see the file for
Eleanor shellstrup is that what you have
or do you have a cactus I have yeah sure
you have the file and not a cactus that
is correct I have Eleanor shell straps
file I do not have a cactus excellent
please give me the file here you go
thank you Janet you're welcome what the
[ __ ] did you just do I I didn't have a
choice if I said I was Sloan Nate would
have known I've been lying to him this
whole time so you think I give a slick
[ __ ] about you and your middle class
love puppy with his original [ __ ]
teeth is it really that bad to have your
own teeth well George had his own teeth
until he started losing them at age 85
so you tell me sweetheart how old is
George he's 89. and now I get to watch
every night as he takes his whole entire
mouth out and puts it in a [ __ ] glass
okay well I'm sorry but this really
isn't my fault of course it's your fault
maybe if you had maybe fire Santos or
maybe he'd actually lived in Florida for
183 days this year I was working on my
medicine
[Music]
I was just about to
cut a million dollars to charity but now
I guess I'm gonna donate that money to
the U.S [ __ ] government
actually as long as you do need to make
those charitable donations because if
you don't if makes the taxes go even
higher
money doesn't count as material things
money's all online now I could sue you
but I obviously wouldn't get much so I
think I'm just gonna call the cops and
tell them there's a strange man in my
house don't do that Sloane no [ __ ] slow
[ __ ] Nate Jillian is everything okay
Nate we really have to leave why what is
happening I called the police
and I'm the actual owner
the [ __ ] I'll explain everything to you
once we're outside but we really have to
leave right now
you're not going anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
open up the doors and let us out right
now
I will kill Gigi I hunt snakes for a
living you didn't know that but that's
like my main job so I am fully capable
of murdering a cat yeah I really here
Gigi's a clone anyway so I can probably
just call the lab and order a new one
maybe the Technology's gotten better and
this one we'll have so many goddamn
emotional problems